every single Sund dial ever made has a
figure eight on it you would use the
figure eight to adjust the fact for the
fact that the sun was either slow or
fast so that you'd get the proper time
accurate to it in about a minute or two
so you might ask how come the sun is not
behaving it has to do with the fact that
Earth's orbit around the sun is not a
perfect circle when we are closer to the
sun we are moving faster in our orbit if
we move faster in orbit than when we're
farthest from the Sun we have to turn a
little bit extra to complete the sun's
Journey from noon to noon not only
because we're in motion around the Sun
but because sometimes we're traveling
faster and sometimes we're traveling
slower those conspire to make a figure
eight and that figure eight is called an
[Music]
analemma